[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's going on guys jake here from joke
world doing another video today reading
your comments uh the poll question for
this one was who would be the best comic
to be stranded on an island with between
bobby lee theovan tim dillon joe rogan
and then other in comment this poll had
28 000 votes which is almost our entire
audience and almost 500 comments
so now i'm going to read each and every
comment in order
no i'm just kidding i'm only going to
read the funny ones so when i posted
this poll i didn't really know what the
goal of it was like are you trying to
survive on the island is it for your
entertainment um and you guys kind of
took that and ran with it a lot of you
went straight to cannibalism like who
are you gonna eat who could eat you a
lot of you are trying to figure out who
would taste the best which honestly
might be its own poll one day and we'll
get to all those comments too but the
number one comment on this poll was from
kuchi officer which is a hilarious name
and he said if you're vietnamese let's
just say theo isn't your best option
which takes us to our first clip of
theovan on the joe rogan experience
basically explaining exactly what he'd
do if his plane went down and was
stranded on an island so i think this
clip will give us some good insight if
you answered theo what you'd kind of be
dealing with on this island and let's
hope you're not vietnamese man i think
about that kind of stuff like if a plane
crashed i already know i'm planning to
head did i eat a vietnamese guy why um
because that's easy it's a starter move
if you attack somebody bigger if you eat
somebody bigger in front of other people
it's going to alarm people
but you you got to eat a small person so
stature is important i think if you gum
down a viet people aren't going to be
that upset at you
vietnam these people are going to be
super upset what are you talking about
somebody's dad yeah they're
they're more
understanding of things dude is this a
character you're playing no
but if you eat a black dude you eat a
black lady and her family's there
they're gonna be pissed so you think a
vietnamese person won't let you slide
i think that they'd be much more
forgiving over a couple of day period i
think uh they're relatives you don't
think so honestly one thing no i don't
think so i definitely think they'd be
super pissed at you especially
modernized ones but what is interesting
is like vietnam is one of the few places
where
americans can go back to vietnam and
they don't seem to hold any grudge at
all
exhibit a
[Laughter]
exhibit a man honestly
well asian people in general are just
much more forgiving and understanding it
seems like i feel like i think i mean i
don't have much i think i think that's a
giant generalization it probably is you
know i mean i did a fast for like four
days and then i was at the best buy
and um
and i remember this vietnamese guy was
trying to help me out and i couldn't
even hear him i was so hungry
and i couldn't you did a fast for four
days oh dude yeah what are you trying to
prove
i don't know man i was probably just
dealing with some stuff and i was just
trying to find a different way to handle
it you know right um
and then i remember this vietnamese guy
and i remember thinking if everybody
turned the other way for a second i
could eat this young fella you know ben
his name was ben actually
over there in westwood
um
but and i've never thought god it's so
ridiculous well i mean but here's the
thing i'd never thought that before so
you only thought you got to the verge of
cannibalism after just four days yeah
damn how much weight did you lose i
probably lost about four pounds but
pounds i needed too you know but i got
clear man i could and i could hear
swear to god y'all could hear somebody
fold a piece of bread from 80 feet away
bro i was so hungry dude i could hear a
[ __ ] skittle hit the cement
across the street i really could man
so if you pick theo you have about four
days before he starts trying to eat you
uh day two he's probably gonna be a
little hangry day three he might start
you know looking at you funny start
getting some seasoning set aside for you
then day four especially if you're from
vietnam that's gonna be it for you so i
would take that into consideration when
uh voting on this poll
for sure see i would probably think that
theo would be the you know the front
runner the poll ended up eight percent
bobby lee 35 percent theovan 5 tim
dillon and then 48 for joe rogan a lot
of people base that off of they think
rogan would be the easiest to help you
survive longer with more outdoor skills
i'm not really sure if that's even what
we're going for i was kind of basing it
off who you want to hang out with the
longest from our second channel i
commented uh rogan for survival tim for
entertainment thea for companionship and
bobby for food just because i think
rogan would be the best outdoorsman i
think tim would be the most entertaining
you know just kind of sitting there
ranting and raving at you and it'd be
fun to watch for a few days maybe not
the rest of your life personally i'm not
really trying to survive if i ever was
in a plane crash straight on an island
especially if i was with a professional
comic i think i would just kind of chill
and be like well this is how it ends you
know let me get a good three four days
out of this
maybe a week if i'm lucky but i don't
really want to be struggling for that
long like barely surviving i think that
i'd be cool just you know chilling
treating it like a vacation until i kind
of pass away that way this guy says yep
no one cares if you eat a little asian
person especially if no one's around to
see it that's pretty funny i definitely
eat rogan first he's got the healthy
fats and probably tastes like elk bobby
would throw me right out of ketosis okay
i said bobby for food because one for me
he'd be the easiest to kill and two i
like asian cuisine but now that i think
about his diet and his smoking like this
person said it might be pretty gross to
eat bobby lee and i guess joe probably
would taste the best
this is weird this guy said rogan would
drive everyone crazy after a certain
time theo would be the easiest to work
with that's what i'm saying but i don't
even know if we're trying to to work on
anything like i just want to relax
you know rogan would get hard to work
with i think he'd be very demanding of
you as a partner in crime on this island
i think theo
might thrive in this environment i think
it might even remind him of his
childhood i think he could get together
a bunch of obscure objects and put
together some sort of raft that looks
like it wouldn't work but could actually
you know get us to safety i think theo
is a really underrated person surviving
on this island and i think clearly bobby
would be the worst pick this guy said
anyone who says stevie's brother has no
self-preservation instinct
that's funny bobby would be the worst
for surviving he'd be very entertaining
but bobby lee and bad friends listeners
will know why which is this next clip of
bobby lee explaining what he would do if
he was in this situation plane crash
same situation as theo this is what
you'd get out of bobby
on a deserted eye like you and i let's
say you and i
are playing a plane crash we're the only
survivors where you and i end up on a
deserted island okay you wouldn't want i
would be the last person you'd want
there why because i would have to say
i'd go tribal real quick
you'd try to kill me yeah like as soon
as we got on the beach you'd look up i'd
be completely naked with a spear trying
to have like like some sort of like
makeup on my face and be like
and i'd just speak the language
immediately yeah immediately yeah wow
already like you know like in um a
return of the jedi when they took uh
uh um han solo and they were in the
rotisserie the ewoks oh yeah yeah you'd
be already in that yeah i mean so you
would kill me you think you'd kill me
my whole thing is i think see my
scenario is we crash on an island i'm i
have to gather and collect everything
because you're laying down
you're finding a way to play candy crush
on the sand in the sand no i would need
to probably rest
because i would honestly like honestly i
would be like on the beach like this and
i'd be first probably sunburned as [ __ ]
see i would i would and then i'd be
looking up and you're like chopping
things down i'd be climbing a tree
getting coconuts
right and i'd just be less laying and i
would probably contemplate my life like
why am i [ __ ] on this island with
this piece of [ __ ] see after two days of
no water and you not doing anything to
try to get food for us
i would have one of those nightmares in
the middle of the night where i grab a
coconut and i smash it over your head
because i think he's got protein i can
eat him without a doubt yeah you know i
would see you and i go because i'd lose
a lot of weight really fast because i
knew that i would know that about you
trying to kill me
yeah yeah i'd already have the spear
ready to go really right up front but
the moment i die are you gonna try to
eat me
i'd probably [ __ ] you first [ __ ] me and
then right when the body is warm yeah
yeah i mean still warm she'd [ __ ] me
because i probably won't have a warm
hole for a very long time i can promise
you that when i kill you i won't eat you
or i won't [ __ ] you yeah oh really i
wouldn't [ __ ] you would it be funny if i
[ __ ] you ate you and i walked across
to the island as a resort
in hawaii
you think you're deserving of [ __ ]
you're just in maui yeah i'm in maui and
then they're like why is that naked guy
with the spear with the big blood
dripping from your mouth and just like
yeah what is that
that's what to expect out of bobby that
would be fun though well not getting
killed or eaten or
him having sex with your dead body but
before that it would be pretty fun and i
bet wherever you're going on the plane
before it crashed
would be fun and it'd probably be fun
beforehand so maybe i'd pick bobby
you've also got to remember you get a
cool plane ride you know before this all
happens rogan will find some damn elk
within the hour probably be forging some
dang jalapenos it sounds like theo vine
wrote that comment himself actually
people picking rogan for survival forgot
where theo grew up
exactly i think that he'd thrive in this
situation i'm telling you he'd contract
some sort of device he'd be straight
we'd be fine
but also i'd be fine if we didn't try to
escape and if we were just chilling
together i think that'd be just as good
because i don't want to do all the work
to survive dude if my plane crashes they
got me i'm dead i'm happy to be on the
island for a few more days anyway so
that's all just bonus time really you
should have died in the plane crash i
don't want to escape joe rogan if you
want to survive tim if you want to
experiment
we do forget that tim is gay
um
theo if you want to relax which is what
i'm saying and bobby if you want to test
out being a cannibal okay so that's
pretty much almost exactly what i said i
feel like both theo and joe would be the
first to resort to cannibalism
yeah four days with theo tim would be i
think the most likely to kill you he
seems like the most likely to just not
care and just kill you like right away
even if he's not hungry i think tim
would kill you even if he's not hungry
just because he had a chance to do it
if i was with bobby my first thought
would be we're dead for sure that's what
i think
this guy said brendan shop just do the
rest of the world a favor
let's face it tim dillon ain't gonna
make it bobby would have to die because
he'd get too weird i'd be worried about
theo eating me but joe probably knows
some stuff and he's definitely having
more people looking for him that's a
that's something i didn't realize well
all these people are pretty famous and
we're happy with looking for him but joe
would definitely
be like on the news like joe rogan on an
island but that's also taking the
question a little too seriously i feel
like rogan would go crazy quick and try
to eat me not me and thea would go look
for a vietnamese person together that's
funny that's what i would want to do
homer simpson
commented that and that is my official
take on the poll me and theo finding the
vietnamese vietnamese guy together joe
would make you collect materials to make
a sauna an ice bath while he's making
kettlebells out of rocks theo on a
deserted island we're gonna split this
coconut or not dog that sounds like joey
diaz to me slothman710
bobby lee's absolute worst option even
with tim he would at least feed you for
a while who do you think would be the
easiest to kill though
i think it'd be bobby and i think joe
would be the hardest
and then i just think theo would
probably be
second hardest to kill just because he's
in better shape this is it at least i
know theo would bring some water and
toothbrush gang gang we gotta pull that
clip
what's that clip
nervous that i'm not gonna be needed
anymore in the future you know as a
comic
yeah sometimes there's a comic i think
about that but also just as like a human
well you'll you'll be something whether
or not needed is what you need
you know i don't know if needed is what
we all need we think we need needed
because we don't like to feel unneeded
or unnecessary so we like to be desired
so we want to be needed right
eventually we're going to have to
probably
replace that with fulfilled
replace that with uh joyful with uh
gratitude with enjoying the experience
that's going to be that's a tough sell
too which makes me nervous sometimes
we're going into the matrix
i'm gonna get my stuff first
what would you bring if i said hey dude
you can go in the matrix but uh you can
bring three things
i'd have to bring a picture of my family
and then i'd have to bring probably
i'd bring probably some water
i would
think you need water in the matrix i'm
not going to be the guy without it in
there imagine if you're the only one
smart enough to bring water you're like
well everybody hold the [ __ ] on yeah i
don't have enough water for all of us
yeah that's my feeling i need some of
that water and you give it to someone
and you're like fighting them trying to
get the water back like [ __ ] you i'm
dragging the water a brother sound like
a brother would drink all the water out
of my grass man i'll probably give it oh
and i would take a knife in there like a
small knife a small one yeah or maybe a
toothbrush
you're the only person with a freaking
nice grill in the matrix you're getting
some puss bruh oh you think you get
[ __ ] in the matrix from having a nice
grill i hope so man or i don't know if i
care about that i just i don't want to
be in there without some of my little
bit of a creature comfort because if i'm
feeling uncomfortable i'm there because
if i take my same feelings and i feel
uncomfortable when i'm in this matrix i
understand then i don't want to
not at least have like something to
clean my teeth or to
you know maybe like a like a scarf or
something something to make me feel
right more comfortable i totally know
what you're saying yeah yeah i don't
want to be the dude in the matrix what
would you take in there
i would assume that physical objects
would be useless
so i would just go oh
but the water might be a good idea
the coolest thing about theo van is that
he's completely serious when he said
that and like joe's laughing like it was
a joke and theo just is looking at him
like
you know
i'm serious like i would i'm he's being
genuine he wants to take water and
toothbrush because he doesn't want to be
the only one without it now it's time
for the horniest comment of the day
brought to us by mo he says annie l for
obvious reasons i'll see myself out now
thank you moe
someone else said something like that i
think everything would be completely
fine if joe was there theo would be the
funniest and you might make it home on
like a couple of turtles that were just
being good turtle citizens giving a
couple brothers a ride
tim would also be funny and he'd have
the most spectacular complaints but
you're for sure going to die and bobby
dies within the first hour i imagine he
would just [ __ ] himself and pass out and
then get eaten by some weak animal that
doesn't even eat meat
that's pretty much exactly how i feel
about the situation
i think thea might be able to get you
home on some jiang stuff that
you know you don't trust at first but
ends up working really well i think that
joe would be so demanding of you
and you would get sick of it so fast and
he wouldn't be trying to crack jokes i
think the other three comics would be
trying to crack jokes in this situation
i think joe would be so serious not even
trying to like make you laugh and um
but you would survive longer
so it's really just a give and take for
what you're looking for
unless you're mo then you know what
you're looking for and that's annie
letterman joe rogan if the plan is to
get off the island but theo if you're
permanently stuck in ireland so we're
all on the same page pretty much all of
us
are thinking the exact same thing with
this question which is cool doug
stanhope bert kreischer burnt chrysler
we have a runner-up for horniest comment
of the day which says nikki glazer for
obvious reasons
that's not a bad way to look at it if
you're planning on not getting off the
island it's not a bad way to look at it
this guy said joe rogan's wife
which is
next level
next level horny by scott wall she's not
even a comic at least other people pick
some female comedians and try to you
know still answer the question scott's
just straight out of pocket with that
one that's funny tommy buns burton tom
shane gillis it's really a mixed bag for
the other but joey diaz is definitely
leading if bear grylls made a knock
knock jokes that count trying to get
home asap
me and joe rogan hunting fishing working
out getting high
this guy is having a fantasy land in his
head right now about just spending the
summer with joe on the island
everyone says joe would eat them i don't
i did not think about it like that
justin schwartz said i'll take esther p
annie l and sarah s because i ain't no
homo that's another way to look at it
people have a few different ways of
looking at this see i think we're pretty
much on the same page here we know what
we're going to get out of every guy i
really underestimated how much my
audience thinks about eating comedians
or comedians eating them so i'll take
that into consideration in future polls
make sure you go check out the community
section on our channel to vote and
comment on these polls in the future if
you want to be featured in a future
video thanks for subscribing and liking
and watching this whole video i really
appreciate it you know this is a fun
thing for me to do make these videos so
yeah thanks for watching really
appreciate it we got some good stuff
coming up this month for you guys make
sure to stick around subscribe and i'll
see you guys later thanks
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]